[Music]
hello dear friends welcome to our
program i'd like to know
a program that is broadcast live on
tuesday afternoons
at 4 30 pacific standard time
we're glad you decided to join us and
you'll notice that i'm by myself uh
james rafferty would normally be here
but he had to travel to san francisco
last
night for uh an emergency
and he's okay and his family's okay
and he got back at four o'clock in the
morning so he didn't get much sleep and
then today he's having it
to do some things so he was not able to
be with us
so i'm going to do it solo today
i just want to remind you that if you
want to send us your questions
you can do so at the following email
address
tv at some tv dot org you'll see it on
the screen
tv at some tv dot org and
you know we'll do the research and
insofar as it is possible we will
try and answer your questions we have
several interesting questions today i
don't know how many we'll be able to get
to
but before we proceed to answer the
questions we want to
ask the lord to be with us so i invite
you to bow your heads reverently as we
pray
father in heaven we thank you for the
privilege now of spending a few minutes
answering some questions that have been
sent to us we ask for the guidance of
your holy spirit
i ask lord that you will help me to give
biblical answers
and that those who have sent the
questions might be satisfied
with the answers that we provide and we
thank you for the privilege of prayer
and thank you for hearing and answering
us for we ask it in jesus name
amen okay here is a
you know somewhat of a humorous thing
before we actually get into a serious
question
this is a comment somebody wrote to me
honestly
your bald dome is part of you why cover
it
the insinuation is that i need to just
totally
shave off my hair but actually this is
the way i've combed my hair
all throughout my life i do have less
hair now but i do have enough hair
to cover my dome so
i don't have a toupee this is actually
my hair because many people wherever i
go ask me
so anyway that's just a little side
sidelight as we begin
the second part of what i want to read
from this same person
is a very important question and it says
this
the health message is just as much a
part
and forgotten by many as the three
angels message
now the person who wrote this is
absolutely correct
i want to read revelation chapter 14 and
verses 6
and 7 verse 6 speaks of the everlasting
gospel and verse 7
actually has three imperatives so let's
read revelation 14 verse 6.
then i saw another angel flying in the
midst of heaven
having the everlasting gospel to preach
to those who dwell on the earth
to every nation tribe tongue and people
and then notice
verse seven saying with a loud voice
fear god and give
glory to him and then it says a little
bit later in verse 7
worship the creator so three imperatives
the first imperative is fear god then
another one
give glory to him the third worship him
now i'm particularly concerned about the
phrase that says and give
glory to him how do we glorify god well
we glorify
god by revealing his character but we
also glorify god
by what we eat and by by what we drink
in other words if we eat and drink the
wrong things we're not glorifying god
you say now where does the bible say
such a thing remember the expression
give glory to him now let's go to
first corinthians chapter six and verses
nine and ten
first corinthians chapter six verses
nine
and ten um let me see here actually
verses nineteen and twenty first
corinthians six
nineteen and twenty very well-known
verses it says
or do you not know that your body is the
temple of the holy spirit
who is in you whom you have from god
and you are not your own for you were
bought with a price
now notice this therefore glorify god in
your body
and in your spirit the spirit is the
mind of man and in your spirit
which are gods so notice the same phrase
that we find in revelation chapter 14
verse 7
it says here glorify god or give glory
to god
in your body and in your spirit body and
mind
which are gods so this tells us
that we are to glorify god with our body
and if we're eating and drinking things
that
damage the body we're certainly not
bringing glory to god because our body
is not ours
our body belongs to the lord let's
notice also first corinthians chapter 3
first corinthians chapter 3 and verses
16 and 17. once again
this uh this these two verses reiterate
what we just read in first corinthians 6
it says do you not know that you are the
temple of god
and that the spirit of god dwells in you
if anyone defiles the temple which is
the body
jesus spoke of the temple of his body so
if anyone defiles the temple of god
this is serious folks god will destroy
him
for the temple of god is holy which
temple
you are so this is serious
it says if anyone defiles the temple of
god god will destroy
him let's read one more statement that
we find in second corinthians
chapter 10 and verse 31. ii corinthians
chapter 10
and verse 31 probably a very well known
verse
and it says there uh the following
therefore whether you eat or drink or
whatever you do
do all to the glory of god
so you'll notice here that
the apostle paul tells us that we are to
glorify god
in what we eat and in what we drink
that's why the bible tells us that there
are certain things that we should not
eat like for example unclean meats
pork and things like that i know that's
not a popular thing to say
but the bible makes it very very clear
the bible says thou shalt not kill
that would include by the way smoking
and taking drugs
because this actually kills the person
not immediately
but slowly the commandment does not say
thou shalt not
kill quickly the commandment says thou
shalt not kill
so if we're shortening our lives by our
health habits
then we will be held accountable by god
so we find in the first angel's message
a call to glorify god and the apostle
paul makes it clear
that we glorify god in our body in our
spirit
that we are temples of the holy spirit
and we are supposed to take care
of this body that god has given us now
there's a problem and that is that many
times the right arm of the message
which is the health message for many
people it becomes the entire body
the health message becomes the
all-absorbing only thing
in other words our people become
judgmental of other people who don't eat
and drink the way that they do
well we need to be very careful about
that
it would be preferable for us for us to
try to persuade people
rather than to be critical of people
because of what they eat
and because of what they drink we are to
allow the holy spirit to do his work
on the mind and on the hearts of people
and then
the holy spirit will persuade them to
change their dietary habits and their
drinking habits
rather than us threatening them and
saying don't you know you shouldn't be
eating that
don't you know you shouldn't be drinking
that and i can give you an example
my wife grew up in a home where people
ate meat
and during the first 14 years of
of our married life together she um
when we went to a restaurant ate meat uh
we did need it at home
but uh she ate meat when we went to the
restaurant
you know i never actually said to her
don't you know what ellen white has to
say about eating meat you should quit
eating meat
i never did that i said the holy spirit
will persuade her eventually to stop
eating meat about 14
years into our marriage one day we went
to a restaurant and she
said you know i think that probably i
should stop eating meat
and from that day on she never ate a
piece of meat again
in other words it's repugnant to her
today
who did the work was it me lecturing her
was it me uh scolding her
no it was the holy spirit we are to
allow the holy spirit to do his work
slowly rather than us trying to do the
work
of the holy spirit is the health message
a part
of the first angel's message absolutely
but let's remember it's the right arm
it's not the entire body
so anyway that's this first question
that came into us a very good question
and i trust that
the question has been answered now we
have another question here
actually we have two or three but let's
go to this one first
it says what is the context of
revelation 19
and verse 20. so let's go to revelation
chapter 19
and verse 20. uh it says there the
following
then the beast was captured and with him
the false
prophet who worked signs in his presence
by which he deceived those who received
the mark of the beast
and those who worshipped his image these
two
were cast alive into the lake of fire
burning with brimstone
so this text tells us that the beast and
the false prophet
are cast into the lake of fire now here
comes the question
what is the context of revelation 19 20
does the text apply to the end of the
millennium
or the second coming of christ well it's
very clear that this text is speaking
about the second coming of christ
and we know that because if you read
verses 11 to 14
actually 11 to 16 you're gonna find that
it describes the second coming of jesus
christ
so this text is dealing with uh events
that take place at the second coming of
christ
of course the big question is uh it says
these two were cast alive
into the lake of fire burning with
brimstone now we need to understand that
the beast and the false prophet
are not individuals they are systems you
know it's
the picture here is that these systems
when jesus comes a second time
are going to be consumed with fire at
the second coming
you say but i thought that that happens
after the millennium
well it does happen after the millennium
but but it says in revelation chapter 20
and verse 10
something that appears to contradict
that i'm going to read the second
question
and then you'll see where i'm going with
this if the latter
in other words if r revelation chapter
um 19 and verse 20 is dealing with the
second coming
how does it resolve or harmonize with
revelation 20 verse 10
especially if you consider the modern
translations
which speaks of the devil being cast
into the lake of fire
where the beast and the false prophet
were
so let's go to revelation chapter 20 and
let's read
verse 10. revelation 20 verse 10 it says
the devil who deceived them that is the
hosts of the wicked was cast into the
lake of fire and brimstone
where the beast and the false prophet
are
now um it gives the impression that uh
the beast and the false prophet are
going to be burning all during the
millennium because this is after the
millennium
so how do we reconcile the idea that the
beast and the false prophet are cast
into the lake of fire at the second
coming
and then it appears that they're
consuming all during the thousand years
and then they're cast in and then we
find in verse 20 that the devil is cast
into the lake of fire
after the millennium how do we
understand this well
we need to understand that in revelation
chapter 20 and verse 10
there's a little word that is added that
does not belong to the text
if you have a king james version you'll
notice that
let's read verse 10 again the devil who
deceived them
was cast into the lake of fire and
brimstone where the beast and the false
prophet
are the word are is added to the text
so really what you need to do is decide
what
which verb you are going to add there it
would be much more logical to say
the devil who deceived them was cast
into the lake of fire and brimstone
where the beast and the false prophet
were cast
not where they are cast but where they
in other words they're destroyed by fire
at the second coming
these systems and then satan is cast
into the lake of fire after the
millennium
once again with the beast and the false
prophet but the beast and the false
prophet are not suffering
all during the millennium they're not
there for a thousand years consuming
and then satan is cast into the same
lake of fire after the thousand years
no we find that satan is cast into the
lake of fire
that the beast and the false prophet
were cast in
before the millennium now somebody might
say but pastor bohr the bible says
that the wicked are going to burn after
the millennium satan is going to burn
after the millennium
yes that's true but the bible also
teaches that the wicked
will be consumed at the second coming of
christ
you say well where does the bible say
such a thing well let's go
to ii thessalonians chapter 1. ii
thessalonians chapter 1
and let's read verses 6 through 8. it's
talking about the second coming of
christ
ii thessalonians chapter 1 and verses
6 through 8. actually let's read
verse 7 for the context and to give you
who are troubled rest in other words
jesus is coming to give those who are
troubled rest
with us when the lord jesus is revealed
from heaven
with his mighty angels see that's the
second coming when jesus is revealed
from heaven
with his almighty angels and how is he
going to come
in flaming fire taking vengeance on
those who do not know god
and on those who do not obey the gospel
of our lord jesus christ
verse 9. these shall be punished with
everlasting destruction from the
presence of the lord
and from the glory of his power
so you'll notice that at the second
coming of christ when he comes with his
angels
we are told very clearly in verse 8
that he's going to come in flaming fire
to destroy the wicked notice also second
thessalonians chapter 2 and verse 8.
ii thessalonians 2 and verse 8. it says
speaking about the antichrist and the
lawless one
will be revealed whom the lord will
consume
with the breath of his mouth and destroy
with the brightness of his coming so the
antichrist
which is the same as the beast that we
read about in revelation chapter 19
actually is going to be consumed by fire
at the second coming of christ
but the final punishment will be the
consuming
in the lake of fire after the thousand
years and then
once the wicked and satan are reduced to
ashes
then god will create a new heavens and a
new earth
so in short the answer to this question
is that there are not two lakes of fire
there's actually one lake of fire in two
stages
the first stage is when the wicked are
consumed
at the second coming and the second
stage
is when the wicked the beast the false
prophet
and satan are consumed in the same lake
of fire
after the thousand years so i trust that
this has been satisfactory
and i think that the bible makes this
very very clear now let's go to another
question
that somebody has sent us i want to read
the question
and then i will make some comments
uh a while back i did a series on the
twelve sons of jacob
and i mentioned that ephraim and
dan were not going to be in the kingdom
and i want to read the question because
it takes
issue with what i said this is the
question
elder i would encourage you to retract a
statement made
that no one of the tribe of ephraim will
be in heaven
because the two most notable characters
in the bible
came out of the tribe of ephraim that
is joshua and samuel please share your
thoughts on this point
thank you so in other words this person
is saying
that two great heroes from the old
testament
were members of the tribe of ephraim and
those two persons
are joshua and samuel so how is it that
i said
that the tribe of ephraim was not going
to be in the kingdom
well we need to understand that i was
not referring to every individual who
belonged
to these particular tribes to dan and
ephraim
the simple fact is that people who
belong to the tribe of ephraim
can change tribes before the close of
probation
and those who have the characteristics
of dan can also change
tribes before the close of probation and
so we need to understand that an
individual
that belongs to a certain tribe and by
the way when we say that they belong to
a tribe we're not talking physically
we're not talking about genetically or
you know as descendants of those who
belong to the tribe
we're talking about character traits of
the individual
because each of the son sons of jacob
had
certain character traits that everybody
in the world
has the character traits of one or
another
of those 12 uh sons of jacob
so they the 12 tribes actually
come from the 12 sons of jacob and they
represent character qualities
now let's notice the book of hosea
let's read some verses now hosea chapter
4 and verse 17. hosea
chapter 4 and verse 17.
here the prophet inspired by the lord's
spirit said
ephraim is joined to idols
let him alone
basically that's saying probation closed
for those who
choose to remain members of the tribe of
ephraim
in other words because their characters
reflect the qualities of ephraim
ephraim was joined to idols therefore
god gives the command
let him alone
so we can't say that joshua and samuel
had the character traits of ephraim when
god said ephraim is joined to idols
let him alone now what about
dan by the way ephraim is not mentioned
among the 12 tribes of revelation
chapter 7
which is describing the 144 000 that
will be in the kingdom
both ephraim and dan are missing from
the list
in the book of revelation so let's talk
for a few moments about dan
let's go to genesis chapter 49 genesis
chapter 49
and let's read one of the character
traits
of dan it says there
dan shall be a serpent by the way
a viper by the path
that bites the horse's heels so that its
rider shall
fall backward does that sound like
the character description of someone who
is going to be in heaven
i don't think so this is a
very vile characteristic
it says dan shall be a serpent by the
way
just like satan a viper by the path
that bites the horse's heels so that its
rider shall fall backward in other words
dan
is instrumental in leading other people
to fall now are there going to some
be some people who belonged to the tribe
of dan
by their character qualities that are
going to leave those character qualities
and are going to become members of
another tribe absolutely
no doubt about it now i have a series
that i haven't done yet at secrets
unsealed
it's on the burner uh hopefully on the
front burner
where i'm going to show that the 12 sons
of jacob their
character qualities are parallel to the
character qualities of the 12
apostles interestingly enough you see
you have dan among the 12 sons of jacob
and you have judas
among the 12 apostles now you have
simeon and levi who were very very
violent individuals in the old testament
and in fact you know they were the ones
who had
all of the all of the men of
second circumcised and then when they
were in great pain
they attacked them and destroyed the
entire city of second
and so um you know these individuals had
extremely violent characters
and yet they are found in the list
of the saved in revelation chapter 7. so
how do we understand this
i think that something will help us
understand this by going
to uh two apostles that had the
character qualities that we find
for simeon and levi in the old testament
let's go to mark chapter 3 mark
chapter 3 and let's read verse 17.
mark chapter 3 and verse 17.
here it's speaking about the two
the two individuals that were extremely
violent
disciples of jesus it says there in mark
chapter 3
and uh we'll read verse 17 317
the following words james the son of
zebedee
and john the brother of james to whom
jesus gave the name of boa nergis
that is sons of thunder
were they pretty violent were james and
john pretty violent individuals
yes before their conversion they
certainly were
you say how do we know that well let's
go
in our bibles to the gospel of luke
chapter 9 and verse 54. luke chapter 9
in verse 54.
here jesus is on his way to jerusalem
and um you know this is his last journey
to jerusalem he's going to die
and he sent word ahead of him to some
samaritan villages
asked them asking them for permission to
go
through their villages on the way to
jerusalem
and these samaritan villages said no we
don't want you to come
through our towns now
of course james and john were very
incensed
about this denial by the samaritan
villages
so let's notice what they suggested this
is
uh once again luke chapter 9 and verse
54. and when his disciples james and
john
saw this they said lord do you want us
to command
fire to come down from heaven and
consume them
just as elijah did
and yet you know something interesting
ellen white states that there was no
disciple that was closer to jesus
than john and that through the influence
of jesus his
character was changed into the likeness
of the character of christ
in other words we need to understand
that when i said
that there will be no ephraimites
in the kingdom there will be no danites
in the kingdom
i'm not talking about the tribes as such
i'm talking about individuals who have
the character qualities of those sons of
jacob
i hope you're understanding the
difference there will be individuals in
heaven who belonged
to the tribe of ephraim there will be
some that belonged
to the tribe of dan but
through the influence of the holy spirit
their characters
changed and because their characters
changed
they have they belong to a different
tribe
one of the tribes that is mentioned in
revelation chapter 7
where the 144 000 are listed
so i hope that this helps in answering
this particular question
i'm not saying that everyone who has the
character qualities of ephraim and dan
are going to be lost
but they need to change tribes they need
to have god change
their characters well our time is just
about up i want to remind you that
june 21-26 we're celebrating our anchor
school of theology
we'll be studying revelation chapter 15
through revelation chapter 22.
fascinating study i enjoyed writing the
study notes for this class over 400
pages more than
any other group of study notes that i've
written so i want to invite you to
contact secrets unsealed some tv
and ask information of how you can
register
and come and be personally present here
for
this special class that begins on a
monday and ends
the following sabbath thank you for
joining us god bless you
and i hope to see you at our next
program i'd like to know
[Music]
you